[Music]
on this friday night
too many patients not enough staff
canada's hospitals buckling
under pressure this is really the
heartbeat of our our health system and
if we're
saturating that we are in trouble and
the dire predictions of a tougher winter
the two teenagers accused of murdering a
calgary police officer on duty
he's everything you would want in a
quality police officer
life after brexit i've been let down
indeed we've been prepared
how the divorce deal leaves the united
kingdom divided
and special deliveries it gives a little
cheer for like the whole unit
the first babies to be born in a brand
new year
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
sonya diol good evening thanks very much
for joining us
it is the start of a new year and many
canadians across the country were able
to ring in 2021
at home with their families but for
frontline healthcare workers
it's been a very different story many of
them among those working
as the clock struck midnight they're
struggling to get the upper hand on a
sharp surge in covert 19
cases hospitals in virus hot spots are
losing ground
across the country and that is leading
to major concerns about burnouts
we are absolutely in a public health
pandemic crisis right now
we are seeing higher case counts but
more importantly we're seeing more of a
strain on the health system than ever
before
the situation is especially bad in
ontario where they've had
days of record infections and hospitals
are now
in a real crisis as sean o'shea reports
some doctors are warning canadians to
get ready for a much
tougher winter
a new year but a persistent pandemic and
one that is only getting worse
especially in hospitals and health care
centers i think
the people of ontario should brace
themselves for
any possibility coronavirus cases filled
up ontario's hospital in spring
trailed off in summer but have been
climbing steadily through the fall
spiking since christmas there are now
twelve hundred cova 19 patients in
ontario hospitals
337 in intensive care units this is
really the heartbeat of our
our health system and if we're
saturating that we are in trouble
we should be taking this seriously well
before these numbers were this high
behind growing numbers real people
who've lost their lives to kova 19
like jenny ewen's grandfather chuck ping
lau
my family is obviously very upset about
this
grandpa would have been there at
christmas time if it had been any normal
year
euan wrote about the toronto nursing
home where her grandfather died before
christmas
the tender care living center he was one
of 52 residents
to lose their lives in a covet 19
outbreak the residents of these
long-term care homes are people that
built our country they deserve a lot
better they don't deserve to be left
alone
to die on their own even if it is a
pandemic and this warning from the
ontario hospital association
it's a very difficult uh position that
ontario is in
and the winter is uh looking like it
will be brutal
in terms of uh the the fight in alberta
with the highest hospitalization rates
for cova 19 in the country
tents have been set up to help treat
patients it's a terrible
brutal lonely way to die for people that
might
not have taken this seriously before
perhaps this is a wake-up call when
you're starting to see your health care
system stretch beyond capacity
and for example hospitals they're not
able to care for people the same degree
that they did before just because of the
influx of patients with copa19 requiring
admission and care doctors are pleading
with canadians to do their part
please stay home i know there's a strong
desire to visit family
and friends but your decisions today can
save lives wear masks physically
distance
and follow public health guidelines even
if precautions are taken
experts warn the worst days are still
ahead shawn o'shea global news
toronto alberta premier jason kenney
says he
takes a responsibility for some
controversial travel
taken recently by senior government
officials
this week he called his municipal
affairs minister tracy allard
back from a hawaiian vacation with her
family kenny says he knows
other government staff have also
traveled abroad recently
and says technically they didn't break
any rules
that's despite recommendations against
unnecessary travel
i believe that these individuals acted
in
what they believed to be good faith have
complied with the legal requirements
including the coveted public health
orders
but for those of us in leadership i
acknowledge that is not good enough
we should be here at home plain and
simple
if we carry a position of public trust
kenny's now ordered all cabinet
ministers and senior government
officials not to leave the country
unless it's for urgent government
business scientists around the world
are working to track down cases of a new
variant of covid19
so far it's been identified in at least
33 countries including
canada the variant is believed to be
more transmissible and as roslord
explains
that has health officials in this
country concerned
as countries worldwide examine the new
variant of covet 19
the top scientist at canada's national
microbiology lab
says there are troublesome indicators
the changes in that variant
may make the spike a little bit stickier
so it makes it a little bit easier to
to interact with its target and that may
be
a reason for the observation that it may
be more transmissible
the variant is definitely getting around
in addition to the uk which has imposed
strict lockdowns to limit its spread the
world health organization says the
variant has been reported
in other countries or territories in
canada
the number of infections is relatively
small but the variant is showing up in a
growing number of provinces
epidemiologists say there's no evidence
the variant is more deadly
but it does appear to be more contagious
and that raises the stakes for canadians
if you increase transmission by 50
percent
then you have a higher proportion of
people entering
the hospital system a higher number of
people entering possible systems so
the probability of an overwhelmed system
just got higher
epidemiologist ray watt dion anden says
current vaccines should still be
effective
but he says there are still many
unknowns about the variant
including how it spreads among children
the national lab suggests
canada is on top of coveted science
we've been able today to sequence about
1 in 20 of every
case that has been detected in canada
state 1 in 20 might not sound impressive
but dr poliquin says that sequencing
rate is equal to or better than most
countries suggesting policymakers will
be guided by solid evidence
in navigating which new measures to take
in the new year
ross lord global news well in the u.s
this new variant of covet 19 has now
been found in florida
health officials confirm it's been
detected in a man in his 20s
with no recent history of travel
authorities are now trying to pinpoint
the source
the new variant has also been found in
colorado and california
experts believe it's likely spreading in
other parts of the u.s
as well and the new year has started on
a somber note in the u.s
the number of confirmed covert 19 cases
is now
more than 20 million the race to
vaccinate
millions of americans is on so far just
over three million doses of coronavirus
vaccines have been administered
many say the rollout is still not moving
fast enough
medical experts warn it's going to take
several months for enough americans to
be vaccinated
to turn the course of the pandemic
jennifer johnson reports
in florida the elderly and health care
workers are camping out for hours
waiting to be vaccinated phone lines
crashed trying to take appointments
now it's first come first serve i blame
our whole government
i mean i totally blame our government
that this is this is not what it should
be
i did not expect to be sitting here
since 3 45 this morning
there are similar scenes in other states
in tennessee there are massive
traffic jams as people await their
inoculations the trump administration's
operation warp speed
let each state decide how the shots are
distributed adding more pressure on
regions already overwhelmed with testing
and hospitalizations
if we're not able to get through that
first phase as fast as possible that's
going to push the whole chain
down in terms of time and as we're
seeing every day means lives
thousands of lives president-elect joe
biden is pledging to get 100 million
shots administered
in his first 100 days in office using
the military if necessary to speed up
the process
meanwhile in wisconsin police have
arrested a hospital pharmacist
accused of intentionally spoiling more
than 500 vaccine doses
the 57 recipients of those vaccines have
been notified
at this time there is no evidence that
the vaccinations pose any harm to them
other than being potentially less
effective or ineffective
los angeles county is now the country's
epicenter of the pandemic with icu beds
and morgue space exceeding capacity
after a heartbreaking 2020 health care
workers across the country
are hoping for better days ahead i'm
looking forward
to paying back some of the precious time
i've missed with my family
due to the demands from chronovirus i
want to do more fly fishing and sign
less death certificates
but it may take a long time for those
wishes to come true americans have rung
in the new year
facing another dire warning from the u.s
centers for disease control and
prevention
predicting the covet 19 death toll will
likely hit 425
000 people in three weeks jennifer
johnson
global news washington israel has
vaccinated a larger share of its
population against covid19 than
any other country a million people have
now received the first dose
of the covert 19 vaccine that is more
than 10 percent
of its residents prime minister benjamin
netanyahu was on hand for the milestone
moment there are more than 45 000
active covert 19 cases in israel
in the uk top medical officials are
warning that hospitals across the
country are at risk of running
out of intensive care beds within days
as the more infectious variant of covert
19
is spreading emergency field hospitals
that were built at the start of the
pandemic are now being
reactivated to handle the expected surge
of new cases especially
in london university college hospital
that is one of the largest
medical sites is warning it's on track
to become
virtually covered only the uk has
recorded more than
50 000 new daily cases of covert 19
for the past four days well today
marks the first day in 48 years that the
uk
no longer has to follow european union
rules or regulations
the brexit process took almost five
years
it also cost two prime ministers their
jobs for brexit supporters the move away
from europe
is all about independence but as redmond
shannon now reports
the terms of its divorce deal could now
threaten the
unity of the uk
the movement to bring the uk out of the
eu goes back
decades and it has some of its roots in
british or more specifically
english nationalism delivering us from
48 years of subjugation to eu
laws and european court jurisdiction
and regaining our sovereignty the uk now
has that sovereignty back
the power to strike its own trade deals
and to better control immigration
but the price could be a heavy one
brexit threatens to potentially tear the
united kingdom
apart on new year's day these trucks
arrived in northern ireland coming from
other parts of the uk a journey within
the country
that now requires customs declaration
forms
for many shipments that's because the
brexit deal has effectively
kept northern ireland inside the eu
trade bloc
for the province's pro-british unionist
community
which generally supported brexit it's
the worst
possible outcome i think the deal has
made northern ireland place a part
i've been let down indeed we've been
portrayed by the prime minister it
promises to be no
border down the rac who promises several
things
sadly has failed to deliver on them all
ironically for the
pro-irish nationalists who were against
brexit
this all feels like a step closer to
their goal of a united ireland
ireland is changing ireland is in
transition the next decade will see
significant changes in the
constitutional framework and makeup of
ireland
europe you are always welcome
across the irish sea the scottish
nationalist government says it wants
back into the eu
and out of the uk this year's scottish
elections could prompt a new
independence referendum the deal is
shocking for scotland
it will damage our economy it will
damage people's well-being and we didn't
vote for it
the people of scotland did not and do
not give their consent
to be removed from the european union
there will be consequences to this it
appears as though resolving one
nationalism project has only served to
stoke
some others redmond shannon global news
london
tragedy strikes the calgary police
service
coming up an officer murdered and the
two teenagers
accused plus a tale of two american
presidents
the vastly different responses to the
pandemic
breaking news in calgary tonight where
two teenagers wanted
in the murder of a police officer have
now turned themselves in
sergeant andrew harnett died late last
night after being hit by a driver
allegedly fleeing a traffic stop harnett
was a 12-year veteran of the force
prior to joining calgary police he
served as a military police officer
the 37 year old was committed to
policing and his community
right up until his very last moments
part of the reason we've been able to
progress this investigation as quickly
as we have
was as a direct result of some
exceptional police work done
by andrew prior to his death
he is helping us solve this and bring
those responsible
to justice nineteen-year-old
amir abdul rahman and a
seventeen-year-old boy who can't be
identified because of the youth criminal
justice act are now both in custody
police suspect the younger teenager of
driving the suv that struck sergeant
harnett
and dragged him down the road harnett's
death has left a huge
impact on his colleagues and the
community flags
outside the calgary police headquarters
are now at half-mast
flowers have been left near a statue and
there's a growing memorial
near to where the officer was fatally
struck
still ahead biden time the countdown to
america's next
leader and how different he is to the
last one
well less than three weeks from today
joe biden will be sworn in as the 46th
president of the united states
biden steps into the oval office at a
time of unprecedented crisis at the
height of the covert 19 pandemic
tonight our jackson proskow looks at how
he's going to tackle those challenges
and how the biden era will be vastly
different from the past four years
under president donald trump when joe
biden steps onto this platform to take
the oath of office it will signal a
dramatic shift in america's pandemic
response
the inauguration itself will be a scaled
back mostly virtual affair
in stark contrast to crowded events held
by president donald trump during the
most dangerous days of the pandemic
we have a president who has not
acknowledged the burden that this
disease has had
at all other than his own brush with the
virus and talking about how
essentially easy it was for him to quote
get cured
no country has suffered as badly and few
leaders have been as openly defiant of
the virus
the virus will disappear it will
disappear
wear a mask americans may be surprised
at how vastly different things will look
under president biden
beginning with his call for a national
mask mandate
we can save tens of thousands of lives
if everyone would just wear a mask
for the next few months where trump
focused almost
exclusively on the development of a
vaccine
biden has said he wants to get the
pandemic under control now
to bridge these deadly days and the day
when most americans are eventually
vaccinated
making the case to the american people
that whether or not you thought this was
a good idea a year ago
now that there is a vaccine on the
horizon what you want to do is hold out
until you can get it
while trump rallied against lockdowns
for damaging the economy
we can't have the cure be worse than the
problem biden has argued things can't
return to normal
if the virus is still spreading rapidly
the bible administration has been pretty
clear
that they see that the key to start
restarting the economy is to deal with
the pandemic
so they don't see these two things as
being in conflict with each other
the biggest difference may be in the
simple acceptance of science
trump promoted bogus cures is there a
way we can do something like that
by injection inside or
or almost a cleaning and muse about
firing experts like dr
anthony fauci
biden has made fouchie lead medical
adviser on the pandemic
none of that will end the bitter
ideological divide
masks are still highly contentious so
are shutdowns
biden himself has admitted there's no
magic cure for all the suffering
the biggest change may be in the way the
new administration communicates with the
american people
expect more experts more consistent
messaging and
more signs that the white house is
actively engaged in controlling this
once in a generation crisis
jackson prosko global news washington
up next midnight arrival how a family's
first born
marks a canadian first
on a brand new year meaning brand new
babies many fresh faces were welcomed
into the world today
a montreal baby is believed to be the
first baby born in canada
in 2021 little arthur arriving precisely
at midnight
less than a minute later baby thomas
making his debut
in toronto eric cavella has more on
those bundles of joys
that are celebrating a new beginning
it was a really a surprise what started
out as a pandemic pregnancy
now a new year's baby meet thomas
little guy born 48 seconds after
midnight at humber river hospital
he came one week early are we planning
to have baby
next friday but it just happened
it was really fast excited to ring in
the new year after a
difficult 2020. it's been um
a very unpredictable time so like we're
not really sure what we're walking into
usually when we come onto the floor
so it's kind of nice to end on like a
nice sweet note that we do have the
midnight baby thomas was followed by at
least three other babies born in the
toronto area
other hospitals had their first baby
several minutes past
midnight for those nurses and doctors
helping to deliver the newborns
it gives a little cheer for like the
whole unit that's been working hard for
the whole year i just
like the name as for thomas and family
2021
is off to a good start he's doing well
he's at his first bath
so he's doing well and parents are
really excited and i think overwhelmed
with how big of a celebrity he is
i think i was pretty hopeful about 2021
beforehand
he's definitely a welcome addition
to the family a sign of a new beginning
in what will hopefully be
a much more positive year erica vela
global news
and that is global national for this
first friday of
2021 i'm sonia dion and we're going to
leave you tonight with a new take
on an old new year's day tradition happy
new year everyone
ouch backyards replacing crowded beaches
for canada's first
virtual polar bear plunge the brave
tapping into their creativity getting
cold for a special cause
in the courage polar bear dip raising
money for world vision canada's clean
water projects
happy new year thank you very much for
watching good night